do you know why the Phoenix fits on the  right hand at the Opera she is his  guardian his protector does she support  aful and strong your job is to bring  honor to the family do you think you can  do that  citizens we are under attack from  northern invade  their leader calls himself Oricon fights  alongside of which no survivors  by eating of his Imperial Majesty every  family must contribute one love to fight  a few no son I am blessed with two  daughters I will fight  we must be strong  this time he will not return loyal brave  and true just my duty to protect my  family  ancestors please protect her  what is your name soldier partying  committer son of haja  we're gonna make men out of every single  one of you  [Music]  losing  the spirits is evident  or something hold its you back  [Music]  when they find out who you are they were  shown you no mercy  [Music]  I'm Hamelin I will bring honor to us all  you  you